it's crazy that you like you have a
moment where you're if you're willing to
kind of sit back and like think you're
like oh that makes sense that's why
I love I I red pilled my friend for the
first time like that's one of my
favorite series I've been doing less of
them lately you can only do so much I've
been traveling but that's my favorite
series I've done on my channel because
you can just see the wheels turning like
on these girls like for the first time
and they're even further back than me
where you're talking about like the pay
Gap but when you explain the pay Gap to
girls that have always believed there's
a pay Gap it's like you see the wheels
turning and they're like oh so that's
not real